um so hi everyone today i'm gonna be
talking about the ongoing efforts to
modernize the columbia river treaty sort
of the agenda
um the columbia river treaty was
originally signed in 1961 so i'm going
to go through the historical context
that led to that
signature talk about the 1961 treaty
negotiations and outcomes and then i'm
also going to talk about the ongoing
case for modernization and the ongoing
treaty negotiation process so covering a
lot of time periods here
um
so a little bit of sort of a
geographical overview
the columbia river basin
is over 250 000 square miles which is
larger than the entire area of france
the basin includes more than half of
washington and oregon almost all of
idaho and parts of montana nevada utah
and wyoming
and approximately 15 of the basin is in
the canadian province of british
columbia where the columbia river which
you can see here on this map in purple
originates um and then in southeastern
washington the columbia river meets the
snake river
and
together that feeds into
the pacific ocean
so
the united states and canada have a long
history of bilateral cooperation
um
they share the longest international
border between two countries and
um there are sort of bilateral
negotiations date back for centuries um
as far as water diplomacy goes the
origin of this
is the 1909 boundary waters treaty which
was signed to kind of come up with an
approach for preventing and resolving
disputes over the use of shared waters
um
it was it established an international
joint commission to help the two
countries carry out its provisions and
at the time um disputes over water most
notably on the niagara river and the
east coast um we're already creating
tension along the border
um so the treaty provided this framework
to deal with these disputes um it held
its first meeting in in 1912 and it has
worked over the last century plus to
resolve more than 100 matters raised by
the two federal governments
so the columbia river treaty more
specifically
came about um during this era of
hydropower expansion in the united
states and canada which is sort of
symbolized
um
in the 1930s with the construction of
the grand coulee dam in in washington
um and during about a 20-year period
more than a dozen large dams were built
in the columbia river basin
mostly for hydroelectric power purposes
they also benefited flood control
navigation and other irrigation projects
um the construction of these dams had
and continues to have a negative impact
on the ecosystems of the basin for
example the completion of the grand
coulee dam eliminated salmon runs from
the mainstream columbia river and its
tributaries in british columbia
so
the specific impis for the columbia
river treaty was a major flood
in 1948 the river was abnormally high
due to deep snowfall and large
rainstorms and it breached a dike in
vancouver oregon which is
an industrial suburb outside of portland
and the town was completely submerged um
18 000 residents were displaced 51
people were killed and the estimated
property damage was over 100 million
dollars so you can see here on the right
a picture of the town right after the
flood
um so the original treaty emerged in
response to these two sort of
one trend of hydropower development and
then the specific
flood control needs um
that were raised by the the vanport
flood so
agreeing to agree
in 1944
canada and the u.s had requested that
the ijc determine whether a greater use
than is now being made um
of the waters of the columbia river
system would be feasible and
advantageous and then four years later
after the van port flood detailed
studies began
and what followed was 11 years of
discussions and analysis
two requests by the u.s for approval of
the libby dam in montana which is
pictured behind me my virtual background
um two proposals by columbia river
companies to build canadian dams
committee hearings in the us senate and
the canadian parliament
and a gradual acceptance by the us of
the idea of sharing downstream u.s
hydroelectric benefits
so 11 years of negotiations
um
and then another
round of formal negotiations begin
february of 1960
and then ultimately the columbia river
treaty is signed by president eisenhower
and prime minister diefenbaker in
january 17 1961.
um the us senate approved it almost
immediately but ratification took an
additional three years in canada
largely due to um
british columbia needing to
negotiate with the canadian federal
government to clarify issues of
authority and responsibility
so that was sort of the original round
of negotiation processes um and the
treaty as it emerged has two primary
focuses hydroelectric power and flood
control
the terms of the tree specified that
canada would provide
about 15 million acre feet of storage
usable for improving the flow of the
columbia river
this is really for flood control
purposes to minimize downstream flood
damages
in both the us and canada
and as compensation the u.s made three
lump sum payments totaling 64.4 million
dollars to canada when the dams were
completed and that amount was based on
an estimate
of um half of the present value of
future u.s flood damages prevented
so
the operation of the um columbia retreat
storage creates hydropower benefits in
both countries
and the crt requires that the downstream
power benefits in the u.s
due to the operation of the canadian
storage be shared equally between the
two countries
this is known as the canadian
entitlement
and under the terms of the treaty
canada can opt to sell the entitlement
back to buyers in the u.s
and actually to pay for construction of
the dams british columbia sold the
canadian entitlement to a consortium of
utilities in the us for 30 years
beginning in 1964.
um so the treaty
really is sort of premised on this idea
of mutual gains to both countries both
in terms of flood control and
hydroelectricity
however
there were also sort of losses created
most notably the treaty made no explicit
provision for other values such as
water flow benefits for salmon and
steelheads or
continuing to exacerbate these ecosystem
problems created by this era of
hydropower expansion
um so
these are the three
here you can see a map of all of the
dams in this in the system
um the three dams in canada up here can
you see my mouse
um in purple and the libby dam in
montana so those are the four dams that
were built
as a result of the columbia river treaty
but the the consequences of the treaty
affect the entire hydroelectric power
generation across the entire um basin so
it's like
very very involved um even though there
were only three dams actually generated
as a result of the treaty
um so the treaty has been sort of widely
regarded as an example of successful
cooperation
and successful trans boundary
negotiations really built on this
foundation of mutual gains in 2011 when
the renegotiation process began
the british columbia um government came
out with a statement saying that the
columbia river is known throughout the
world as one of the most successful
models of a transboundary water treaty
other countries see the agreement as a
benchmark on cooperation to create and
share benefits
um
so i thought that was sort of an
interesting statement and while the
treaty did authorize this equal sharing
of
additional hydropower
um
results from additional water storage
and coordinated water releases um there
were also
the negative impacts of the dams weren't
necessarily equally shared by the two
countries
um so the united states had
fairly significant adverse impacts on on
fish
and salmon
habitat and some losses of land but in
canada as a result of the three dams
that were constructed um
there was major flooding and dislocation
of entire communities so canada
although they were ultimately
compensated for it
uh did have sort of more significant
negative impacts as a result
of the treaties
um
so
the case for modernization um the
columbia river treaty has no expiration
date um but 2024 is significant um
because it is the earliest that the
terms of the treaty can be terminated
um
and so without renegotiation also in
addition to the termination provision
without renegotiation the flood control
provisions will shift
um so this presents an opportunity for
the united states and canada
um as well as other stakeholders on both
sides of the border
to reconsider the scope of the treaty
and evaluate its effectiveness
um
and i think within a water diplomacy
framework the fact that this
renegotiation process is baked into the
initial agreement is a strength um
we can talk about whether like the
60-year timeline is too long but i think
it is interesting that none of the
original negotiators expected that the
original agreement would last forever
um but at the same time this has also
introduced some measure of
conflict i guess um because everyone
wants the treaty to be updated in a way
that reflects their priorities
and values um so
thinking about modernization uh which is
the word being used by the negotiators
there's sort of five main issues that
that have been raised during these
ongoing conversations
um this is not an exact an exhaustive
list lots of other things have been
brought up as well but i think it sort
of summarizes the most significant
arguments so i'm going to walk through
each of these five
um so first as i mentioned
issue number one is that 2024 um
the current flood risk management
provisions
change to a less defined approach and
instead of canada providing a set amount
of flood control every year it will be
as an on an on-call basis
and the u.s will pay on an annual basis
based on how much flood risk has been
assessed
um
so this is sort of the core part of the
original treaty and it will expire
unless measures are taken to renew
or modify it
and in addition it is the earliest date
at which the treaty can be terminated
provided that either canada or the
united states provides 10 years written
notice
um no one has provided this so the
treaty will not be determined in or be
terminated in 2024
um but it it sort of
catalyzed this
um
era of renegotiations beginning around
2011 2012.
that's issue one
um
issue number two is that since the
original treaty negotiation
process in the 1960s
um
stakeholders outside of the main
negotiating parties have argued that the
treaty neglects ecosystem needs so the
renegotiation process has opened the
door
for a variety of environmental advocates
in particular the dams built as a result
of the treaty have altered the river's
ecology and contributed to the decline
of salmon fisheries so
in a 1995
opinion on the impacts of the entire
columbia river power system on salmon
noaa the national oceanographic
association
had set flow objectives at each of the
columbia river bays and dams
in the last 20 years the spring target
has been missed roughly 20
27 percent of the time so 27 time
there's not
adequate flow at these dams for salmon
to pass
um and in the initial studies about
renegotiation the u.s and canadian
entities
didn't address any of these ecosystem
needs they only addressed updating the
power and flood control agreements
although subsequent documents have
addressed
incorporating more ecosystem-based
function requirements so you can see
here on this map on the right
where
there are
salmon passages
and where
the dams have prevented any kind of fish
migration so everything north almost
everything north of
the canadian border there the salmon
habitat has been completely destroyed
um and in particular groups that have
been harmed by
the original treaty and who have
advocated consistently
for um considering salmon habitats are
the canadian first nations in the united
states native american tribes
um
and you can see here on the right um
the historical
land of the yakima umatilla nes pearson
warm springs tribes who have formed a
coalition
to advocate for um
incorporating ecosystem functions in in
the modernized treaty and that that
group came out with a statement
recently that said that any
modifications to the treaty must ensure
full engagement and consent from tribes
and first nations and be in alignment
with articulate
articulated indigenous governance
principles so they're advocating
essentially for expanding the formal
negotiation
team to include representatives from
native american tribes and first nations
next
stakeholders sort of responding to these
needs on both sides have identified
ecosystem functions as a key component
of a modernized treaty
the u.s came out and said that there's
an opportunity for inclusion of certain
additional ecosystem operations
and the bc side the british columbia
side said basically the exact same
statement
um there is certainly a lack of clarity
about what exactly ecosystem functions
mean
uh it's sort of become a buzzword within
this negotiation process
um and a lot of uh stakeholders trying
to advocate for clarifying and
determining what exactly are
we thinking about when we're talking
about ecosystem functions
and then finally
um the terms of the canadian entitlement
have led to conditions that disadvantage
u.s electricity consumers
because the canadian entitlement
specifies that all power generated
downstream
would be split evenly among the united
states and canada
although the energy market has changed
considerably since 1964.
so the original economic assumptions
were based on forecasts of declining
downstream power
but these proved to be incorrect
and so the the power sharing agreement
has
ultimately
been more favorable to canada than to
the us
and um the u.s entity has proposed
rebalancing the
power benefits to better reflect the
actual value of the coordinated
operations
um however some northwest politicians
believe that the terms of the treaty are
beyond repair
and uh introduced a bipartisan
resolution in the united states house of
representatives calling for its
termination um
well this seems unlikely
uh it is another sticking point in the
renegotiation process
so um formal negotiations opened on
may 30th in 2018
um and in june 20th 2020 the 10th round
of treaty negotiations occurred via web
conference
um and at the conclusion of those most
recent conversations the two sides
released almost identical press
statements which i've excerpted on this
slide
um
due to the confidential nature of the
cross-border negotiations the specific
details of canada's initial proposal and
of the us framework that they're
referencing here aren't have not been
made public
um and this lack of information has been
really frustrating to the numerous
stakeholders who
regard modernizing the treatment treaty
is essential
um
so in 2018
a coalition of 31 non-profit
organizations
sent a letter to the u.s entity
advocating for among other things
the expansion of the u.s negotiating
team to include a broader range of
stakeholders and greater transparency in
the negotiation process
so i'll talk a little bit about like how
the negotiations actually work um
each side is represented by an entity
and the u.s entity is made up of the
state department
the bonneville power administration
which covers multiple states in the
pacific northwest
and the northwest division of the u.s
army corps of engineers and the canadian
entity is um represented by the canadian
department of foreign affairs
trade and development um
and the bc hydro
power authority
and so these are the sort of formal
negotiators but in addition to those
teams there are numerous other
stakeholders
who are not formally involved in the
negotiation process but have
um claims to the basin so these include
for example states and their legislators
a large assortment of ngos and other
non-profits
public utility districts
and tribes in both the united states and
canada
so
as far as like thinking about what comes
next and trying to imagine
sort of how this treaty might resolve
um as i said the negotiations are still
very much in progress and there's not a
ton of information about how things have
been evolving
that said
there seems to be a consensus emerging
around how
they can leverage the treaty to address
ecosystem functions and other
environmental concerns such as climate
change um
this
seems to be a
a priority for
many of the non-formal stakeholders and
has that has been reflected in
statements made by the u.s and canadian
entities
there are lots of stakeholders who all
have various views about how the treaty
should be modernized
and there are even some stakeholders who
believe that a formal treaty is
unnecessary so i think there is sort of
a more
i think it's unlikely that that actually
emerges as an option um but there's a
question of whether the two sides could
cooperate on flood control without a
formal treaty um
or whether you know good good treaties
make good neighbors so
that's where that's where we're at
thank you all for listening yeah
okay thank you jimmy for excellent
presentation i think it's really
nice the way that you have presented
it's really on the food
so now i would like to um
yeah ask mushroom flora to make the
comments
and yeah then we can discuss further
so what do you think will be the biggest
biggest challenge to overcome from the
government side
uh
i think
i think it's sort of this fundamental
question if the treaty that they have
has basically worked for 60 years um and
people have been pretty happy with it on
both sides the us feels like they're
overpaying for power but that's sort of
been the main
objection to the treaty as it currently
stands however i think there is a fairly
broad consensus that the treaty should
be the scope of the treaty should be
expanded to include all of these
ecosystems not all of these ecosystem
services but certain ecosystem services
relating to salmon fisheries and climate
change
and i think figuring out i think the
biggest challenge for the government is
figuring out
to what extent are we going to transform
this treaty that has basically worked
for 60 years
and and sort of brought in the scope of
these negotiations
um
which
i think is just sort of a slippery slope
um
and is this treaty as you know even the
right
vehicle for having those conversations
about transboundary environmental
concerns
i don't i don't know i'm i'm not sure i
actually have an answer to that one um
yeah i think that's the biggest
challenge
uh i'm also thinking something that
since the climate changes in the
climate change is very much in the issue
so
help me understand this because i'm not
that much familiar with the us
government system
so
i was thinking that
for example the last government of the
us
as far my understanding goes
not really very supportive of the
measures to be taken taking about the
climate change and everything
and i know that like in the us there is
spoiler system like once the government
changes almost a major portion of the
administration changes
so with this shift of administration
do you think like that will have a
significant effect on making the future
decisions on this treaty
and if yes then how that might
end up
yeah i think um
i would i would venture yes
i think that even under the trump
administration climate change still
featured in this treaty because
um
if for example there is less snow melt
or less snow accumulation because of a
changing climate that has serious
impacts on you know u.s hydroelectric
power generation and
the economy of the pacific northwest i
think
40 percent of washington electricity is
is hydroelectric
so if there's less water there's less
power and that's quite devastating um to
the northwest economy
so
to that extent i think
it sort of impacts the potential impacts
of climate change on this treaty
had already been taken into
consideration
whether under the current administration
that might be expanded to include
sort of more
comprehensive environmental
values um
it seems possible um
i also think that
this treaty is not a
major foreign policy priority for either
government um
so
it's kind of skated under the radar a
little bit and during like some of the
there were 10 rounds of negotiations and
then some it kind of
was put on hold during the
um
changing government so i think
well whether it will be picked up with
sort of more focus on environmental
concerns i think remains to be seen
actually both the questions came from
my experience as a government officer
because in our case in the u.s or in
most of the developed countries
generally what i see that
although the government's change but the
national policies and the national goals
more or less remain same very minor
changes
unless like some drastic medicines taken
but in this part of the world government
changes the whole thing falls apart and
you start from you so which is why i was
trying to actually understand
this thing so that i can actually design
my my uh my presentation and paper from
that person
thank you very much it was an amazing
presentation and i loved it
thanks mushroom
flora do you have any feedback or
question for gemma yeah yeah i really
really enjoyed this presentation great
job um i appreciate your use of graphics
i think you know making a presentation
is um you know good presentation is
always not as easy as it seems um
so yeah overall i think i learned a lot
it was very easy to follow um i
definitely had a couple points that i
would consider as like further
considerations like not really necessary
but things that came to mind while i was
listening to the presentation so
um i'll run through and you can either
respond or not respond to each one so
the first one is um are there still
opportunities for further hydro power
expansion along the columbia river
because you mentioned that flooding is
still a priority but i know in a lot of
parts of the world hydropower expansion
is really diminishing because we're just
utilizing everything that we can so
yeah so in my understanding there is not
there are no opportunities for
additional dam construction there are
opportunities for
greater efficient like greater electric
efficiency
some dams have been identified as
potential targets for removal which
would then catalyze additional needs on
the existing dams for flood for all
measures
um
yeah those are right that those are the
categories yeah um yeah and so then the
next one um so you talked about this a
little bit especially at the end but um
i was wondering like how climate change
might exacerbate the water resources in
the future and like i guess specifically
if certain stakeholders should be
included so you already mentioned a lot
of stakeholders that are not being
included um but it would be interesting
if like ecologists either
like representing the like two countries
or some kind of neutral
ecology representation to be included in
the negotiations to really advocate for
these environmental needs and not just
the wants of the two countries like
economically or
technologically
um yeah
that's a that's a great question um i
think one of the suggestions that has
emerged in recent years is officially
adding noaa
to the
um u.s entity team to have a better
advocate for sort of environmental
impacts
in that formal body
um
that is one of the things or like other
sort of representatives from the us
department of the interior that could
sort of
be more of a voice for environmental
concerns compared to like the power
administrations who have
sort of clear expertise on the
hydroelectric side
um but aren't necessarily equipped to
consider
you know salmon habitats and things like
that so that's one of the strategies
that has been proposed
um
has not happened yet awesome
um okay so the next thing is about so
you
did a good job of explaining the gains
and losses from the treaties point of
view like which parties were suffering
and which ones were really experiencing
gain but it'd be interesting to learn
more about
like how
this treaty was successful in terms of
negotiation so not just the effects of
the treaty itself but also like
um if people are saying that this is
like the model negotiation treaty it's
i'm sure it's not just because of what
the treaty was able to achieve but also
like how the treaty was negotiated i
think that's like one of the most
interesting things about your
presentation is that it basically refers
to no animosity between the countries
like it took a really really long time
like decades of negotiations but like
almost nowhere in your presentation did
you mention like
well they like really
you know like got stuck on this one
issue or they couldn't move forward
because like this one party was like
not
um cooperating and i i don't know i
think it'd be interesting to understand
like why why is that like it's
must have like something to do with the
negotiations and then also
probably the conditions of what's
happening
yeah that's a great point i have not
really built that in but i think that's
a
that yeah that's super helpful i'm
definitely gonna do that yeah i think
like an easy way is like looking at the
bruno verdini's 12 steps and just
checking off like which ones seem to be
fulfilled and then which ones don't
because i imagine many are checked and
then that's why it was exactly but um
yeah no it was really interesting i
think it's like a big shift from the
case that i'm working on where like
basically the governments hate each
other and like that's why nothing is
able to get forward and i think
it's just um it's interesting to see how
long the timeline is even if the
governments don't hate each other
yeah
i was thinking i was thinking a lot of
that a lot about that after listening to
who's name's case last week um
and like the two they kind of arrived
the us and canada kind of arrived at the
negotiating people with this idea of
neutral gains in mind
and the treaty emerged from that and it
wasn't it's not that the treaty is
enabling an effective diplomatic
relationship the treaty is the result of
an effective diplomatic relationship
um
so how that kind of differs and and how
that might be leveraged for a sort of
more comprehensive and forward-looking
um document going going forward so
yeah that's great thank you so much
definitely yeah no um i'm just trying to
see okay so the last thing that i had
was i mean you mentioned this as one of
your open questions but like it's really
interesting what the consequences for
the different stakeholders would be if
the treaty was terminated
um i think like it seems like everyone's
on the same page that like this treaty's
working it's good but then it's really
weird that like they're unable to extend
the treaty it seems like mainly just
because people are dragging their feet
but um
yeah it seems like in most cases if the
treaty went away
um stakeholders would
have some kind of loss um but
i don't know
yeah thanks for a very constructive
suggestion so any other
suggestions from
um aaron or
cassian or s9
okay
so um
yeah i i would like to ask one thing um
maybe master does top on it you
mentioned five area of new
um yeah
renegotiation
process so um
and um so
what are the disagreement um among these
um areas that you mentioned among the
two parties between
canada and u.s is there kind of
who are you able to explore
the disagreement among the parties
for those
areas that that can
a negotiation might stack
i think one of the things that's
interesting about this case is that the
disagreement isn't necessarily between
the two entities but also between all of
these sort of peripheral or not even
peripheral like they're deeply involved
they're just not part of the formal
process so one of the things that's been
so interesting looking through all of
the documents that have been or the
statements that have been put out by the
us and canada is how
identical they are so they kind of they
after each round of negotiations they
put up these statements they're like oh
we made so much progress like we
responded to their framework we
responded to their framework like things
are moving right along and all of the
sort of
complexity seems to be driven by these
other actors who are pushing for
change so i'm not sure if there's like
necessarily a ton of disagreement
between the
two countries um
around say like the inclusion of
indigenous peoples and the negotiation
process like i think both countries are
sort of
willing to
um expand the scope of the treaty to
think about how those those tribes have
been harmed over the last 60 years um
but the the conflict then is like how
does the
sort of
collaborative treaty mechanism respond
to the needs of these stakeholders on
both sides of the border does that
answer your question
yeah
yeah
yeah well thanks uh so the second issue
that um i wanted to mention that um
uh you mentioned climate sense is one of
the future aspect that
need to be considered
so is there any study that
can provide details what are the
expected impacts of the climate sense is
it
uh future flooding or is it uh the
impact on the
on on energy uh hydropower generation so
i think if you can mention those impact
i think then then it could be much more
i think your succession could be much
more uh solid
yes i think i left that up for
complexity's sake here but i think the
main concern is sort of this shift from
a basin that's driven by snow melt
um to a basin that's driven by rain
uh and as that
like as there is less snowball and more
rain the kind of flood control
mechanisms change as well as the
potential like management of hydropower
over time so
yes i do have sources for that and i
will include those in my final case
study
jim i i've mentioned to you a couple
times along the way
um that
it's invisible
but the states and the provincial
governments in canada are in fact uh
very much calling the shots yeah and uh
they're not officially part of the
entities
but
remember that the
u.s entity is led by the state
department because allegedly this is an
international negotiation and the state
department has no relationships with the
governors of all those states no
long-standing working relationships
which has caused some severe difficulty
for those governors
um
it
it may be
i don't you don't have to do this but
you might want to imagine as a last
little piece of your paper
what it might be like
and how helpful it might be
to imagine a
second track of negotiations convened
by the u.s governors and the provincial
leadership in bc
with first nations and tribes
they would have enormous credibility
they said we're getting together because
we are convinced that the future of this
agreement whether it's strengthened or
renewed or replaced
this it needs to take account
of
changing conditions from 60 years ago
and we feel those when we have
responsibilities
and if they were to organize a set of
sessions with ngos
and find this on their own
the state department i promise you would
come the same way that the canadian
agencies would show up but they wouldn't
be there in their official capacity
and if they just took
three or four questions
maybe even two or three questions
that are not
addressed for the future in the existing
treaty
and and laid out substantively
agreements they might reach
the same way that bruno described
local officials on both sides of the u.s
mexico border initiating their own
conversations
trying to come up with what they'd like
to see as jointly beneficial elements of
a future supplementary agreement which
then became the basis of what the u.s
government negotiated i think the same
thing could happen
yeah and and i i think it's
i think the two big differences between
then and now
are that there were enormous number of
positive benefits to be shared in the
beginning
yeah
and so they were getting together i
agree that everyone who pointed out they
start with friendly relationships
matters but when the actual negotiator
sat down
okay how much flood control are you
going to give me well how much money are
you going to give me
uh and
that was the negotiation
whereas now it's okay what restrictions
are we going to impose what dams are we
going to take down who's going to build
the new flood control
systems if you take down existing dams
to make salmon uh migration possible
it's not all about
allocating gains
that's one big difference
the second is
nobody had those concerns about salmon
and climate and other natural resource
questions and ecological concerns the
way we do now
and
that's not represented well
in the entities
and
but the concerns are there but the
entities can't really negotiate them
very well so i think if you
if you look at what was what's different
in big ways between then and now
that the
response to that that would be most
effective in the short term is to have a
different track
of local and non-governmental and
scientific
negotiators generate
some of the elements of a supplementary
subsidiary version or
addition to the existing agreement
and i think governors the governors in
those states have been tracking every
move in the state department i mean my
engagement in this case i think i
mentioned happened when i was doing
training for the state department and
the two guys who were appointed by the
state department to lead
these conversations who had zero
zero background in anything northwest
water
canada
absolutely just thrown into this and
they were saying so
we got a problem these governors are
telling us that they
want to want to say what should happen
and we don't know how should we
negotiate that that was the question
they're asking is how should we do this
negotiation with these governors who
don't have any official role while we're
trying to negotiate with the canadians
that that was
the conversation and i i don't think
they figured it out and i think there's
the
enormous pressure coming
on the us government uh from the states
it's
a thing i've been trying to untangle is
the relationship of state governments to
their representatives back to the
federal government because so many state
representatives and
senators from the northwest states have
come out with various
you know official statements on their
perspective on these
renegotiations
and like what you know
how are the washington senators
coordinating with the washington
governor to get things back to the state
department like trying to tease off all
of those
they're not they're not
that's for sure that's we're trying to
make political capital on the
legislative side the key is to governors
the key is the the governors have the
access to the white house
yeah the governors
only care later
about getting the senate to ratify any
change in the treaty between now and
then the house of representatives the
governors don't care to talk to them
there's nothing they're going to do for
this so my sense is that when you see
state legislators
and
congressional legislators from the
states
making noise about this issue
it's political self-promotion to try to
gain some advantage from all of this but
it isn't because they expect to be part
of solving it
got it
that's good to know that's helpful
but it is wonderful to have somebody say
there's a successful treaty i think
that's great
a successful water treaty between two
countries wonderful it's basically
worked the way it was supposed to for a
long time
and we have you know we have parallel
negotiations after 50 years in latin
america we didn't spend much time on it
but there are negotiations
um between different countries in latin
america where treaties that existed
over shared waters for 50 years are up
and
you you can't
just extend the treaty
everything has changed so much
but nobody knows well but we've had this
treaty in 50 years it's worked
why should we mess with it well because
the conditions have all changed
but that doesn't that doesn't translate
into a specific
strategy for how to do the negotiation
in my view if
if there is anything we've learned it's
that you need to get all the
stakeholders i mean aaron's one of his
four conclusions you need to get all the
stakeholders into the story well you
can't do that in an official treaty
negotiate renegotiation so you have to
run a parallel effort
and get the other stakeholders
into the substance of what should the
new agreement say and why and and as
bruno shown if you can get agreement at
the next level down from the national
government on the two sides
and you have real players with stakes
and they stay this is what we think
whether it's you're changing the treaty
you're extending it with the new
supplementary terms however you're doing
it here's the substance and we all agree
with it and we'll all support it
and that that for me is how the
what a diplomacy framework
meshes
with the political reality of the treaty
renegotiation
but i think
presentations was terrific it's a
it's such an interesting
circumstance
i don't think you can conclude anything
at this stage but i think you can say
as you have
look this is a problem sweetie
renegotiation treaty extension
here's what they face
here's what how they got into it here's
what they're trying um maybe they could
try this
but i i don't think
anyone could hold you or anyone else
to trying to come up with a conclusion
about any thing in this case at this
stage of the game
i think we're at the lessons learning
phase then we're at the lessons learned
phase
maybe in a few years someone can update
it i hope so
we're giving you a paper to start with
yeah
yeah so thanks zimmer again for for the
presentation also thanks
for the presentation so on
next week we will have um
uh last two cases uh by mass roof and
flora
and as as i already mentioned that the
deadline for submission is on
21st of may so
yeah we are expecting more much more
massive
presentation and also much more the
final piece of your work in the next
week
and um as as i already mentioned that uh
please do us
provide your feedback by
may 24th
i guess you already yeah on the whole
course yeah for the whole course
as you already
add a footnote to what adam has said at
the outset mit has this online
uh give it a rating
uh here's a set of questions uh and then
they
they say what the average score was on
each question by averaging across
whoever happened to answer uh i do not
find this system helpful
um i've never learned anything
from that
device and i have always
asked people to please just send a
paragraph something what do you think
the strengths and weaknesses of the
course are and what idea do you have
about something we could do to improve
it in
in a conversational just rough draft
email
that's how i learn stuff about what we
do in the course and how to improve it
so um
yes mit would like you to please fill
out the formal evaluation form and
we'll live with whatever the numerical
score is whatever that means
but um we really would like to learn
something from you
um no we we made a decision to have
guest presenters particular guest
presenters did we make good choices
did we give them good advice about how
to structure what they were presenting
uh anna mesh
and i tried to provide the water
diplomacy framework in some more
expository way at the outset
we ask everyone to pick a case and write
a case we use the
aquapedia frame
so that people have some common device
because it's worth it because we put
publish your
your paper in the aquapedia i mean so we
make a bunch of decisions those could
all be different yeah and and also
last thing i would like to mention that
last year two students
so one of the students was able to
submit their final paper into a journal
article so it's already submitted in one
of the journal article another student
is still working on that
and another student was able to publish
their article in a newspaper
so this kind of things as these are the
practical things so all these are the
possibilities that you can do and i am
happy to support you
so yeah this i think is
yeah it's very practical so
it's very encouraging to us that there's
pure acceptance and excitement about the
things that are produced in the course
so we tell the stories of people whose
papers became theses or dissertations or
their papers became articles in
peer-reviewed journals or their papers
turned into op-eds um
this is all
um for us
one indicator
that people getting something out of the
thinking reading writing listening
talking that happens in the course so
um we hope you'll think of a way
to capitalize on all the work you did
uh in some other outlets if you can and
we'll help we'll help
some cases it takes another year
to deal with the journal that wants more
elaboration and we will we'll be glad
online to help you if you want to follow
up on any of this
is there any other specific issue that
you would like to mention maybe for the
final paper or other
issue
[Music]
i think everybody's
just doing wonderful work and we're very
excited about the products
yeah
we'll see everybody next week for the
yeah we'll sit last go at this yeah
so all right bye see you next week
thanks